bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de sa bourgade ce soir le défi du
communautarisme à deux mois des
municipales des livres des reportages
des enquêtes se multiplient sur la
montée de l'islam radical dans certaines
villes avant les élections le
gouvernement promet un plan pour contrer
l'influencé des intégristes alors
assistons à une prise de conscience et
quelles sont les réponses possibles
interdire le salafisme interdire les
listes communautaire ou encore donner
plus de moyens on en parle ce soir dans
notre grand débat c'est un portrait
acide d'un homme confident l'avarice
obsédé par l'argent
son âpreté aux gains auraient d'égal que
sa haine pour nicolas sarkozy implique
alips now raconte les années fillon et
ses truffes et de révélations c'est
signé gérard davet et fabrice lhomme nos
deux grands témoins ce soir et puis
cédric villani par ici la sortie s'il ne
se retire pas de la course pour thoiry
et bien il sera exclu affirme le parti
macronix brigitte boucher a plein
d'infos coulisses à nous faire partager
ce soir voilà donc pour le programme
c'est parti hashed accès dr n'oubliez
pas on lire
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir fabrice
lhomme et gérard davet bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'être nos deux grands témoins
on va évidemment parler de votre
deuxième tome sur le suicide de la
droite française
il y a eu la haine sur les années sarko
voici donc apocalypse now chez fayard
les années fillon 2014-2019 je le disais
c'est plein d'anecdotes ces glaçons
tellement c'est violent on y revient
longuement dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission mais je sais que le sujet
vous intéresse on va parler ce soir du
communautarisme car il semble que ce
sujet s'impose ou pas vous nous direz
dans cette campagne des municipales
on en parle avec vous ce soir françois
pupponi bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes député
liberté et territoire du val d'oise
longtemps maire de sarcelles vous
publiez un livre au titre choc
les émirats de la république aux
éditions du cerf on va en parler francis
chouat bienvenue à vous je vous êtes
député la république en marche de
l'essonne longtemps maire socialiste
d'evry dans les pas de manuel valls et
enfin j'accueille u10 rabat et bonsoir
vous êtes conseiller municipal la france
insoumise de corbeil essonnes et vous
venez de signer une tribune il ya
quelques jours dans libération intitulée
marre des communautaristes je précise
parce que le titre n'est pas forcément
compréhensible vous fustigez les prises
de position des manuels macron sur
l'immigration et sur sa lutte contre le
communautarisme vous donne la parole
dans un instant messieurs juste après le
billet de stéphane stéphane blakowski
qui nous plante le décor comme tous les
soirs
si j'ai bien compris c'est parti
bon sang miam on sortait fans ont formé
ce que son problème de parité à nouveau
ce soir mais bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris et myriam en ce début
d'année notre président de la république
a décidé de lutter contre le
communautarisme d'ailleurs il l'a dit
lorsqu'il a souhaité la bonne année à
tous les français il a lié attention -
le communautarisme attention je vais
lutter contre cette année où il a banni
comme ça mais on l'écouterait je
lutterai avec détermination contre les
forces qui minent l'unité nationale
quelles sont ses forces dont parle le
président balles et les communautaristes
c'est à dire les gens fragiles quand je
dis les gens auxerre ça peut être
n'importe quel genre a pas d'amalgamé
les gens qui pensent que les règles de
leur communauté par exemple sont au
dessus des règles de l'art du gua ce
soit un peu et pas très clair votre
histoire est ce que vous pourriez nous
donner des exemples
oui moi ce serait embarrassant parce que
là on est sur lcp donc lien ne soit pas
de discrimination n'est pas sur ces news
un combat pacifique baptisé une
communauté qu'une autre mais bon si vous
voulez absolument un exemple allez je
vous en donne un les islamistes bah oui
les islamistes évidemment on voit là des
communautaristes bon en même temps c'est
pas un exemple j'ai pris tout à fait au
hasard parce que c'est le président de
la république lui-même qui nous a dit
que l'islam politique est une menace
pour la république
c'était en octobre sur rtl il était dans
l'avion donc ça souffle un peu derrière
on écoute dans certains quartiers de la
république dans certains endroits de
notre république il y à un séparatisme
qui s'est installée
c'est à dire la volonté de ne plus vivre
ensemble de ne plus être dans la
république et au nom d'une religion
l'islam en la déployant de dire je crois
à un islam politique et nous allons
vivre selon ses règles qui ne sont pas
celles de la république
on a rit il s'exprime commence ce
communautarisme liées à l'islam
politique et ben françois pupponi je
veux bien tout cas le vip l'accent
tonique chronique et le lion la spirale
en poupe on est bien il a écrit
justement un livre dont il est venu nous
parler sur comment s'exprime cette
commune tarissement islamique dans sa
banlieue mais pour ma part je vais
prendre un autre exemple que celui des
municipales se dire les listes
communautaires ont certains dansent en
octobre xavier bertrand et sur france 2
et il dit directement président de la
république il faut interdire ces listes
communautaire dans l' écoute et je
demande une chose auprès de la
république et je demande aux deux
ministres qui sont là je vous demande de
prendre les dispositions législatives ou
réglementaires et je les soutiendrai
pour interdire qu'aux prochaines
élections municipales
il y ait des listes communautariste
parce que l'islam politique est en train
de vouloir s'implanter jamais ça ne doit
avoir lieu en france
car at il été entendu alors tous dans le
même temps vous savez c'est l'époque
alors oui il est entendu et en même
temps non alors oui pourquoi parce que
15,9 l'a soutenu jadot l'a soutenu
le retailleau déposé une proposition de
loi au sénat dans le même sens pour
interdire les listes communautaire dont
ça fait presque une majorité sauf qu'au
bout du compte
macron a dit pas question et
on peut pas interdire les listes
communautaire ah bon alors pourquoi
eh ben je vais vous dire c'est simple on
peut pas interdire les listes
communautaire parce que ça n'existe pas
aucune liste de 10 mais nous on est
communautariste donc la république on
pense que ces lois sont moins
importantes et bientôt donc évidemment
et les soupçons par exemple aux
européennes ya une liste qui s'appelait
l'union française des musulmans
démocrates pourquoi pas il ya des
chrétiens démocrates qui peut bien y
avoir des musulmans démocrates
donc sauf que comme castaner en bon flic
et d'idées bizarre cette histoire dont
il a fait son enquête il a vu qu'il
avait quand même des soupçons de
communautarisme il s'est dit on interdit
cette liste sauf que c'est pas si facile
myriam on écoute aux élections
européennes il ya une liste qui se
revendiquait justement d'une approche
communautaire j'ai décidé de ne pas
retenir cette liste elle a fait appel au
conseil d'état le conseil d'état a
laissé 48 heures elle a été validée
donc là dessus personne ne peut me faire
de procès donc cette liste elle a pu se
présenter elle a fait qu'un score alors
le fnb au niveau national a fait 0 13%
hong kong du bord franchement si c'est
ça le communautarisme au niveau national
est ce que ça vaut la peine de faire une
émission ne partez pas parce que
attention dans certaines communes le
score est 50 fois plus important donc là
j'ai fait une petite liste de communes
de la région parisienne devaient les
voir où le score de cette liste on
communautariste
a priori en tout cas qui se réjouissait
que cette le vote paul pour cette liste
soit une réponse de la stigmatisation
des musulmans donc quand même voilà on
fait ils font entre 7 et 6 % dans ces
cinq communes donc ils vont certainement
pesé en partie sur les municipales et
donc c'est le début vais évidemment de
forme de communautarisme donc que
françois pupponi décidé d'écrire un
livre sur le sujet mais rassurez vous si
vous êtes inquiet pas de problème macron
a dit qu'il allait s'en occuper donc
c'est bientôt régler normalement de
savoir si des décisions sont prises et
peut-être vous nous direz vous nous des
vrais lesquels françois pupponi on va
commencer par vous puisque vous livre
les émirats de la république il ya des
hemera en france bien sûr un titre un
peu provocateur mais ce que je constate
moi c'est l'avènement depuis quelques
années dans ma circonscription danis de
détenteurs de l'islam politique de gens
qui disent voilà nous sommes musulmans
certains sont proches des frères
musulmans et nous avons décidé un de
structurer ses quartiers nous le disent
nunzi implantons dans le domaine
cultuelle dans le domaine culturel dans
le monde sportif dans le monde éducatif
et nous nous présentons aux élections
depuis quand vous constatez cette
personne depuis les années 2013 14
après que ça commençait un peu à
s'installer et ce processus là il n'est
pas propre à la france a ses quartiers
c'est un processus international
partout où l'islam politique a une
chance de s'installer il essaie de
s'installer donc c'est un processus
qu'on collait parfaitement et alors
décrivez-nous ce processus concrètement
vous constatez quoi vous parler de
retournement de fidèles de jeunes pour
certains radicaliser qui ouvre des
mosquée différentes vos écoles
coraniques
il ya une volonté d'abord de prendre
possession et de défier de diriger la
communauté musulmane d'une ville ont
créé des mosquées on infiltre celles qui
existent on essaie de prendre le pouvoir
de dents et après on essaie d'imposer
une vision très rigoriste de l'islam
parallèlement à ça on crée des
associations de soutien scolaire ont ils
ont par emploi sarcelles essayer de
prendre les mêmes la maison des jeunes
la culture pour y occuper et prodiguer
des cours de danse ça peut être aussi
des dépôts des parents qui se présente
aux élections de parents d'élèves en dix
ans sur des listes indépendantes et
ensuite le dernier maillon de la chaîne
c'est de dire on se présente aux
élections et tout ça se connectent pour
dire voilà nous nous sommes des
musulmans rigoriste nous avons une
vision très rigoriste de l'islam
nous voulons vivre dans ces quartiers by
le dominer la communauté musulmane mais
aussi exister entre l'hôtel et donc on
se présente pour comprendre dès 2014 son
quad et des gens qui étaient là avant et
qui se sont à quoi pas radicaliser mais
islamisés en tout cas dont la non la
pratique religieuse a été plus prégnant
tout ce sont des gens qui se font
installer
comment commencer sont des jeunes des
quartiers qui sont amants se sont
rapprochés d'un islam radical rigoriste
et je fais bien la part entre le
djihadisme ça n'a rien à voir à ses
rangs des gens qui veulent une pratique
très rigoriste de l'islam et qui
essaient d'imposer leur lagon fait
sciemment organise la vie au quotidien
d'un possible changement ils le
cherchent à imposer manière démocratique
parce que ça m'étonnait c'est légal et
démocratique je moi je suis pour ce
délit ce que vous avez fait vous vous
dites aussi qu'il bénéficie de soutiens
financiers
ça c'est la grande question que je pose
à l'état pur moi j'avais contre moi par
exemple sami de bala dernier à l'échelon
législatives
rémy dubaï faut préciser l'ancien c'est
le présent fondateur du comité contre
l'islamophobie en france bon
qui a fait une campagne pleine campagne
les du beau matériel etc
rien qu'à dérouler un peu le prédit
camper lectorale avec des moyens voilà
vous n'avez pas je suis pas je suis pas
un fan enquête particulière mais je veux
juste s'intéressent un peu
il ya d'autres associations qui font du
soutien scolaire avec des magnifiques
que le livre est en papier glacé qui
attirait pour un héros ni mais d'où
vient l'argent donc des questions non
j'ai pas joue pas non je vois juges
constitue pour sceller payer 3 face à
des pays dont la turquie riches
demandent à l'état c'est allé voir quoi
aller voir regarder bien sûr que vous
par exemple quand un groupe de jeunes
turcs qui est qui pratiquent un islam
radical qui est venue j'étais soutenu
par la turquie ou pas voilà donc sur
tout ce qui est sûr c'est que dans ces
territoires en partie à sarcelles d'un
côté il ya le cmj qui est un groupe
reconnurent de l'islam rigoriste en
turquie proches d'erdogan qui s'implante
en france passé c'est de notoriété
publique il s'en cache pas et eux ils
affirment leur vision en tant que turc
d'une de leur manière de vivre le
restant ce que vous décrivez c'est une
forme de machine qui serait en route et
qu'ils commenceraient à prospérer un peu
plus vive et cela aussi français soit
est vrai ou pas mais oui bien sûr
d'ailleurs je précise françois pupponi
je le connais depuis plus de 20 ans nous
sommes des praticiens people depuis nous
avons nous sommes des praticiens d'avon
était maire l'un et l'autre et moi je
fais remonter à bien avant 2013 2014
le processus qui est qui est en cours
rien à rajouter à ce qu'a dit françois
je pense qu'il faut simplement préciser
les termes de quoi nous parlons vraiment
je n'ai pas les talents du chroniqueur
mais tout surtout pas en contre
mais ne parlons moi je parle en tous les
cas d'islamisme politique l'islamisme
parce que c'est précisément le
dévoiement de l'islam de pratiquer des
millions de croyants et qui le
pratiquent dans le respect total des
lois de la république qui revendiquent
eux les mêmes droits que d'autres
pratiquants de religion dans les salles
de même que j'envisage tout on n'est pas
dans les mosquées la majorité des mets
même zone en ouvrant la république
politique mais une volonté politique des
réalités parce qu'il s'agit d'un projet
politique d'un projet politique qui est
de faire vivre dans la république
française des logiques s'appuyant sur
bien des dimensions de crise sociale de
ségrégation territoriale de clitoris
ation de discrimination pour faire vivre
une logique de séparatisme et moi je me
réjouis qu'il y est aujourd'hui tous les
éléments d'une mobilisation pour une
reconquête républicaine que j'espère la
plus large possible du point de vue de
celles et ceux qui y participent en
mettant au centre de cet enjeu là les
territoires et au coeur des territoires
l'alliance entre l'état et les maires
parce que ce que je constate depuis des
années et des années
c'est une sous-estimation du phénomène
c'est le fait que en tous les cas dans
ma famille politique d'origine
à gauche on a totalement sous-estimé on
va parler des responsables s'étaient
engagés dans des politiques ou des
partis ils étaient sur le diagnostic un
instant on va parler des responsabilités
parce qu'on n'en est pas là voilà pour
rien comme ça alors on n'est pas là mais
il faut qu'on en soit là sur la
mobilisation
gérard davet projet politique vous vous
avez travaillé tous les deux vous avez
fait ce livre une xala qui paraît la
seine saint denis avec des journalistes
john seul studio journalistes qui sont
allés sur le terrain c'est un livre
c'était compliqué parce qu'il a suscité
pas mal de polémiques
d'ailleurs est-ce que pourquoi c'est si
difficile déjà de travailler sur ces
sujets là c'est difficile parce que
parce qu'on est on touche on touche aux
contradictions de la société française
moi j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt
monsieur pouponner et monsieur choix il
parle à la fois à la fois comme comme
magistrat premier magistrat de leur
ville il parle aussi ou ancien premier
magistrat il parle comme homme politique
tout ce tout se confond parce que ce
phénomène là c'en est un temps
ajustements tout confondre et donc
effectivement dans l' enquête qu'on a
mené on a supervisé avec fabrice on a
une utilité misé 2 les talents de cinq
jeunes journalistes qui sont allés sur
le terrain en seine saint denis qui ont
passé huit mois qui ont interviewé bien
bon nombre de gens et ils sont allés à
rebours parfois de leurs propres
convictions et ils ont constaté
effectivement que ce que décrivait
monsieur choix était tout à fait réelle
et quand ce livre sorti que n'at-on
entendu ensuite deux journalistes vague
de l'informel 9,3 mieux que ça on a été
attaqué sur des réseaux sociaux par
molly citera pas parce que par charité
on veut dire pas chrétienne forcément ça
sera déplacée mais par charité on citera
pas les journalistes en question mais
des gens et de média important de gauche
qui ont fait des tweets avant des médias
avant la sortie du livre avant la sortie
du livre
juste le fait sachant qu'il y avait un
livre qui allait être fait sur ce thème
et on a été attaqué sur le thème à on va
encore s'en prendre aux musulmans
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
un sujet tabou pour une grande partie il
faut le dire pour une grande partie de
la gauche française qui à mon avis
portent effectivement une grande
responsabilité dans ce dans cet
aveuglement parce que la droite
évidemment a eu tendance à justement
généralisée caricaturé mais c'était le
rôle de la gauche doit de rappeler les
raids
les règles de notre république et qui
sont bafoués dans un certain nombre de
territoires française notamment dans la
banlieue parisienne mais pas seulement
dans le beaujolais
attention la laïcité est menacée 189
qu'est ce qui se passe en 90 et 180
degrés aujourd'hui la gauche est
extrêmement embarrassés et on peut
comprendre qu'elle le soit mais il
faudra en sortir
c'est la crainte que l'on fasse la magan
c'est toujours ce fameux fameuse
islamisme et islam et qu'on mélange les
musulmans de france qui dans leur
immense majorité respecter les lois de
la république et sont les premières
victimes et sont les premières personnes
à des lycées dénoncé d'ailleurs les
mesures qu'ils vivent et il ya des
enquêtes là dessus mais des quartiers ce
serait bien victime ne nous quitte
quand ils peuvent bien sûr je suis
offert et tant qu'on arrive à maturité
de nos murs le problème
nommé claire béni de la gauche
aveuglement qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cela il existe ou pas ce phénomène
d'islamisation dans certains quartiers
dans certains endroits ou pas d'accord
donc bon déjà je vois que la vie est
assez partagés sur ce sur ce plateau
donc on n'est pas seulement peu
représentatif du point de vue déjà
sexuelle et puis en même tant du point
de vue il n'ya pas de même une voix un
petit peu différente maison que je suis
à la faire je suis à la fois intéressé
par parce que 10 mai mais mes collègues
élus sur le lordinot stick d'élus de ces
territoires
sachant que il faut toujours faire
attention évidemment aux paroles
d'experts des territoires de banlieue
etc et de beaucoup d'élus comme monsieur
pupponi ou mais ce choix mais dans votre
tribu l'urd est très agacé par
l'utilisation même de ce terme de
communautarisme oui il existe ou passe
passe est alors jamais dit tout à
l'heure vous avez dit un mot intéressant
c'est un thème qui s'imposent et puis
vous vous avez une petite hésitation est
ce que ces voix là et nous c'est ce
qu'on a voulu dire dans cette tribune
qu'on a passé la semaine dernière dans
le journal libération c'est de dire
c'est un thème en effet qu'on tente
d'imposer sur le scrutin municipal
nous on a fait une une hypothèse avec
mon collègue d'elias in qu'ils aient
lieu à fleury mérogis moins chez lui à
corbeil-essonnes dans l'essonne dans le
même département
on s'est dit il ya d'abord évidemment de
ce point de vue là emmanuel macron a
procédé à ces classiques de de diversion
et de volonté de sortir du moment social
que la france traverse encore
aujourd'hui avec ce spectre du commune
et du communautarisme qui arrivait un
petit peu il faut le dire un peu comme
un cheveu sur la soupe dans son discours
des voeux
après quelques sentences un peu
guerrière sur sur le mouvement social
mais ce qu'on a voulu dire c'est aller
un petit peu plus loin vers s'il ya pas
seulement la diversion il ya aussi une
entreprise à travers ses accusations sur
ce qu'on appelle aussi de formes
d'agressions symbolique à l'égard des
habitants des quartiers qui se
mobilisent une forme aussi de
délégitimation de l'action politique
autonome une forme de disqualification
aussi de gentils qui s'engagent et qu il
y avait des listes la soie d'une
certaine manière la liste citoyenne le
pensionnaire de procès en
communautarisme c'est pas seulement on
va venir dire seulement pendant les
faits pendant le même une manif contre
l'islamophobie vous avez été vous paru
j'étais présent donc ça peut être
interprété comme le fait m qui revient
systématiquement comme une insigne voilà
de la mer il ya deux débats et qui me
passe un peu différent même si
s'interpénètrent parfois moi je sais pas
ce que c'est fait ou une housse
communautaire on voit à peu près ce que
sait sauf qu effectivement juridiquement
c'est difficile parce que personne ne
peut être fichier doit partir at-elle
communauté et qui va décider
première victoire militaire j'ai connu
c'était dans les mines à sarcelles
c'était une liste juive 100% juive la
liste la liste bleue bon voilà beke 600%
d'une des deux personnes de même
confession d ile-de-france sur une liste
pas l'interdire vallier au début on
était opposée données et ces contrôles
qui apprend leur expliquer mais restez
pas à l'extérieur venait dans les
espaces communs donc le communautarisme
les quartiers sont communautariser et
chaque communauté et c'est que d'exister
et puis il faut dire que ça s'est
présenté une confession dans une liste
ça n'est pas interdit par la compote
donc ça c'est le chrétien-démocrate ans
as a service sujet et puis un deuxième
sujet qui est qu'il ya en plus l'arrivée
de l'islam politique est vrai qu'on
reste sur ce sujet-là 2h02 jeu quand on
dit on va lutter contre le
communautarisme
bons caf et redirons contrat dit que la
france accepte distincts politique
compte tenu de ce qui se passe à
l'étranger lorsqu'ils prennent le
pouvoir
est-ce qu'on accepte ou pas c'est ça la
question de mission les réhabiliter je
réponds qu'on y vienne parce que
elles sont bien entendu partager mais
aussi des élus mais parce que est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas aussi entendu d'une
certaine façon un peu complice de ce qui
se passe si bien montré que des élus en
subventionnant telle ou telle
association n'ont pas participé mais
entre les îles entre les élus qui
participent qui subventionne qui aide ce
qui est jeu qui dealent pas entre l'état
qui laisse faire entre ce qui bien
entendu qui a une part de responsabilité
collective de la france la question qui
est posée aujourd'hui c'est à dire est
ce qu'on continue comme ça et est-ce
qu'on accepte l'avènement d'un islam
politique en france c'est tout vu et
cette question il faut qu'on y réponde
et moi je ne prône pour sa seule
présence lui qui répondent à manta qui
anime le décès soit et françois pinet
vous étiez socialiste ya pas si
longtemps on entend un procès de la
gauche qui est fait sur ce plateau
vous vous êtes dur avec votre enseigne
il est responsable en parachute et
j'étais là encore j'étais encore membre
du parti socialiste et encore pour deux
langues deux années et je faisais partie
de ceux souvent d'ailleurs des élus
locaux des maires je faisais partie de
ceux françois pupponi en était partie
prenante également qui exhortait le
parti socialiste a clarifié sa position
sur la question commencent à leur faire
la laïcité et puis et puis à j'ai vu
olivier faur rappeler les fondements
laïques du parti socialiste et prendre
ses distances avec tous ceux et toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont mis des
épithètes à n'en plus finir sur la
laïcité au nom de gros noms de quoi
qu'il fallait privilégier la
reconnaissance de la diversité sans
faire le tri dans cette diversité qui
est la communauté nationale en mettant
en balance
cette diversité avec le fait que nous ne
sommes pas dans un modèle anglo saxon et
que de ce point de vue le en même temps
il a une limite
on ne peut pas être pour la république
française c'est ce que vous dites est
sur le terrain on en voit très bien des
élus qui parfois je suis le poney vous
obliger à partir avec la presse qui vous
a accusé par exemple sur les piscines
avec les femmes dubaï vite d'avoir
leurré des des horaires réservés il n'y
a pas de réserver
il n'y a pas d'horaire réservé une
associe la piscine de sarcelles était
ouverte la piste a été ouverte au public
à des heures fixes et quand on fermer la
piscine pour le public on prêtait la
peau métallique sur la piscine à des
associations
et parmi les associations qui demandent
sur les vues des créneaux associatif il
ya une association loubavitch en disant
je n'avais pas le droit de refuser parce
que si vous refusez à une association
dix ans mais vous êtes des religieux je
ne pourrais pas la piscine vous êtes
condamné par non respect du principe de
laïcité que qui dit que nul ne peut être
discriminé en vertu de s'enfuir
la ligne de crête a lieu tous les jours
tous les élus de france une grande
partie lorsqu'elle est grandes fêtes
religieuses juives musulmanes ou autres
prête des lieux publics des lieux
publics pour l'exercice de fait
religieux et si on le fait pas on
particulier musulmans prient dans la rue
est-ce qu'on accepte j'appuie que des
musulmans prient dans la rue où est ce
qu'on dit bah non c'est pas acceptable
que l'on prie dans la rue et donc à
titre exceptionnel pour deux trois
grandes fêtes
on prête des équipements publics pour
l'exercice d'un fait religieux ce qui
est complètement contraire loi 1905 1,3
et inscrit par l'unesco pas un concordat
pour financer collision moi je suis pour
moi je souhaite que des corses à la
france a réglé le problème qu'ont corbas
pour les juifs en 1905 on arrivait de la
république avec les problèmes de sa
relation avec la communauté avec la
religion catholique est aujourd'hui elle
n'ose pas elle ne veut pas parler
sereinement à la communauté musulmane de
france pour dire comment on fait c'est
quoi être plus juste parce que ces
musulmans recourent dié mais moi je
pense qu'il faut répondre aux musulmans
qui ont des légitimes revendications
pas parce qu'il ne le faudrait pas et
parce que je sais pertinemment que si on
commence par cela on est reparti pour
des années et des années de polémiques
qui ne ne feront pas avancer que c'est
la même chose sur la question des listes
communes le terme excusez-moi faut aller
jusqu'au bout de votre question posée
par des des élus et de la dé certains
s'arrangent d'écouté disons les choses
franchement ça existe et il existe même
des roulades
il était là oui oui il est dix mètres
les relations très étroites parfois
c'est rare et corbeil-essonnes en a été
un bel exemple entre des pratiques
communautaristes dans des quartiers et
du clientélisme financiers avec des élus
moi j'ai des exemples précis en
seine-saint-denis où pour faire battre
une municipalité communiste en l'espèce
à bobigny il a été monté des listes
communautariste par des personnalités
départementales qui s'en mordent bien
les doigts aujourd'hui et donc pourquoi
il ya de tels arrangements et il ya
aussi le fait tout simplement que si des
élus a fortiori des candidats ne se
sentent pas de conforter et d appuyer
par l'état pour qu'il y ait de cette
véritable reconquête républicaine qui
mêle tout le monde des progressistes aux
conservateurs de la gauche même extrême
à la droite pas extrêmes dire que s'il
n'y a pas un nouvel et si si y'a pas un
nouvel esprit républicain qui vit qui
garantissent le territoire alors oui il
y aura toujours des arrangements vous
entendez un format aussi de mea culpa de
la part d'élus qu avec qui vous ne
partagez pas du tout hein
les options je l'entends même d'après ce
que je comprends pointé du doigt les
pratiques de ses alliés locaux à
corbeil-essonnes simplement sur ces
sujets ce qui est toujours intéressant
c'est que mon voisin tout à l'heure des
excès un sujet tabou etc
il ya toujours ce discours là autour de
ces questions religieuses et pas répondu
la question qui se pose est de savoir
robin di consoli se disait je ne vous
avais pas question de finir mon
intervention
merci matt hendricks et un rien dit que
c'est un sujet tabou alors que en
réalité à la fois les discours
politiques et médiatiques sont saturés
de ce sujet on ne parle sur certaines
périodes absolument que de ça et donc de
ce point de vue là je ne pense pas que
ce soit un sujet sur lequel les gens
documenter à une injonction car en
quatre journées mais mon chercheurs je
compte énormément dans les noms mais je
te dire qu'il ya dix neuf ans de trifyl
confiera alors c'est ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la vie et ce qui m'intéresse c'est
encore une fois c'est là pour le coup
alors j'y vais plus être d'accord avec
avec messieurs choix c'est qu'il dit il
faut une reconquête républicaine etc il
est pourtant dans une majorité
présidentielle aujourd'hui qui a jeté à
la poubelle le projet borloo qui
justement parler non pas de reconquête
puisque j'aime pas trop ce terme qui est
quand même pas très flatteur pour les
quartiers populaires mais plutôt en tout
cas de réouverture sur ses cartes on
avait oui bah c'est un peu trop offensif
justement à mon goût pour les le pouvoir
le plan borloo et notamment justement
société assez ambitieux en termes de
moyens publics pour pour ces quartiers
on parlait tout à l'heure pour vous le
droit la principale cause du repli
identitaire parce qu'on le constate
quand même il ya plus dans certains
quartiers de deux femmes voilées qu'il
n'y en avait il ya vingt ans il est dû à
quoi c'est une icône une cause
économique et social ou d'autres
vous voyez le problème le problème c'est
la manière aussi de 2 de progression
bah oui mais vous me dites là la cause
du repli communautaire et puis vous
identifier ce repli communautaire avec
un indicateur qui vaut ce qu'il vaut
mais qu'est pas non plus hyper vérifier
santis fait bien voudrait bleus mais pas
de femmes dans les quartiers pour vous
demander public énormément avec ce que
je sais que j'ai domaine là encore une
fois moi j'étais invité sur le contenu
d'une tribune qui explique justement les
effets dévastateurs de ce type de
d'injonction justement prendre position
sur ces questions là et aussi les faits
assez dévastateur sur la démocratie sur
l'engagement de personnes qui souffrent
de soi ressentir directement ce procès
en communautarisme soit encore pire
parfois s'autocensurent dans leur
engagement parce qu'ils ont peur qu'on
leur fasse le procès en communautarisme
et le contenu des échanges et la manière
dont vous me demandez de manière express
mais notre visite il ya aussi un
problème dans le traitement du sujet qui
vraiment je le dis décourage des
initiatives politiques et contribuent à
une forme est là pour le combat se
retrouver je pense avec mes collègues
élus avec une forme de déconstruction de
disparition de la politique notamment
sur ces territoires
fabrice lhomme vous avez les les
sourcils oui non mais c'est juste
surréaliste comme discours il vous êtes
complètement dans l'abstrait ce que vous
dites ça n'est même pas compréhensible
non parle de choses simples nous on a un
avantage avec gérard davet parmi la
plupart des gens qui sont ici c'est que
nous on n'est pas engagée politiquement
moi je m'en fiche j'ai pas de parti pris
j'ai pas d'idéologie
moi j'ai grandi en banlieue par exemple
gérard aussi et c'est vrai que quand
j'étais enfant j'ai dû me lever dans des
quartiers pas toujours très facile et
pas de femmes voilées
je ne dis pas que ça me dérange des
femmes voilées je m'en fiche totalement
jeudi il ya une évolution
cette évolution elle est constatée elle
est chroniqué par des chercheurs des
universitaires il ya encore eu des
livres eu récemment des gens qui ne sont
pas engagés politiquement
il ya eu cinq étudiants qu'on travaille
là dessus qu'ils disent simplement une
choses basiques c'est que s'agissant de
l'islam ce qu'on ne peut appeler l'islam
politique où l'islamisme c'est quelque
chose qui monte en france depuis un
certain nombre d'années voilà et moi et
là où c'est là où je parle de tabou
c'est que cette incapacité juste à juste
reconnaître ça après il ya des
explications
il ya peut-être des remèdes peut-être
que c'est pas grave dans le livre je
finis juste là dessus après je
laisserais répondre dans le livre
inch'allah fait avec les étudiants on
leur a demandé d'enquêter et de contre
enquête et ça veut dire quoi
ils ont été nos étudiants dans le café
de sevran qui avait été présenté dans un
reportage télévisé qui étaient passés un
peu la postérité comme un repaire
d'islamistes ou les femmes d'exclure va
entrer on est retourné là-bas enfin les
étudiants sont rentrés et qu'est ce
qu'elles ont constaté c'est que c'était
absolument pas un repaire d'islamistes
qui avait effectivement des personnes
d'origine musulmane parce qu'il ya
beaucoup dans le quartier qui venait là
prendre leur prendre un verre qui
buvaient de l'alcool et qu'en fait il
est femme n'était absolument pas
interdit qu'il y avait une construction
il y avait un montage qui a été fait une
manipulation
voilà donc ça veut dire quoi il faut
parler de ces choses faut simplement
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il faut les
nommer il faut nommer l'islamophobie
lorsqu'elles existent il faut hausser
nommé l'islamisation
lorsqu'elle se développe et se réclamant
famille donc ça c'est agréable
mais c'est aussi fini par devenir ce que
j'aimerais bien le processus de
l'avènement de l'islam politique et donc
l'islam y est on est en route
il existe comme les français qui ne
connaissent pas bien ces quartiers ne
savent pas ce que c'est vraiment ils en
ont peur et non et ça donne en dehors
ces quartiers il ya de l'islamophobie
qui montent parce que on ne comprend pas
où on marcherait parce que j'entends dix
ans mais c'est pas normal et les femmes
voilées mais oui les femmes voilées
alors on est en république la laïcité
permet à chacun de croire va croire et
s'il fallait le sol est un voile alors
et donc à force de ne pas aborder le
sujet de la montée de ce procès il avait
abordé c'est pour dire comment on fait
pour régler le problème est que l'on vit
dans la concorde républicaine tels que
sur leur religion nathan la force de
parler du sujet globalement plus haut
niveau de l'état on va éventuellement à
la catastrophe emmanuel macron
l'islamophobie et la montée des amours
eatx et on va pas d'en tirer sur les
manuels macron s'exprime sur le sujet
est connu maintenant on attend de savoir
on a compris on n'a pas fait le débat et
non il a tranché et voilà mais qu'est ce
que vous attendez depuis qu'on a on a
une note de la dgse si extrêmement
sensible que seul le ministère de
l'intérieur a pu consulter 150 quartier
54 est sous l'emprise d'islam radical
évidemment j'ai pas la liste que je peux
vous dire mais non bien sûr que non
c'est dans le jdd je vous renvoie au jdd
ce week-end c'est pas uniquement
l'ile-de-france ce qu'on appelle
beaucoup d'autres endroits jusque des
solutions c'est un nous sommes un pays
laïque où la liberté absolue de
conscience existe
les musulmans ont droit de cité sans
aucun problème en france
ils ont droit de vivre leur religion
tranquillement comme je pose je vaux je
pose la question du financement des
lieux de culte on peut pas dire à la
fois on veut pas que ça soit les
puissances étrangères on veut pas que
sont les collectivités locales
la plupart des fidèles ne peuvent pas
payer l'on se pose à présent la question
d'exécuter par contre moi je pense qu'il
faut restreindre un peu le champ de
l'exercice du fait religieux pour les
élus aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous
présenter aux élections avec un voile et
ça ça pose un problème les
fonctionnaires sont neutres les élus je
pense ne devrait pas exprimée lors
vision religieuse grâce à une
proposition parce que sinon ils sont là
pour restreindre un peu le champ dans
l'espace public transi lorsque lorsque
j'apprends en discutant et des collègues
qui a des musicalité où il ya des maires
adjoints officier d'état civil qui
choisissent dans la liste de mariage à
faire les mariages en fonction de la
consonance des noms ongles religion ou
de la culture supposée est qu un maire
ou une mère autorise ça et c'est
absolument insensé c'était autorisé
en tout cas c'est peut-être permis mais
on vous 17 ans ont refusé sélection
originale choisie choisi chacun choisit
les siens et 10 après midi sous les eaux
je fais une hypothèse mais la réponse
est dans la réponse est dans la question
jour je l'appelle et moi je vous prends
tu as l'impression que ce n'est qu'une
batterie de mesures sur un plan si je
vous prends des messieurs prendre des
mesures j'en prends à eux deux la
question de la déscolarisation des
enfants même si ça reste minoritaire
et même si c'est dans le code de
l'éducation et que c' est soumis a
strictement aucun contrôle de la part de
la puissance publique est ce que l'on
met en capacité
sinon mesurera simple et pratique comme
dirait chevènement est ce que l'on est
en mesure de faire en sorte que cela non
pas s'arrête puisque la déscolarisation
est possible il question la famille est
possible qu'il y ait un contrôle avant
l'ouverture des travaux des mesures
saylan l'ouverture d'établissements
l'ouverture l'ouverture d'établissements
sans aucune déclaration sans aucune sans
aucun contrôle de ceux de ses skis et
encadre sans la moindre connaissance des
programmes et sans la moindre
connaissance des flux d'enfants qui sont
pour certains des enfants qui aidons les
familles ont fait appel à la
déscolarisation pour qu'ils se
retrouvent dans ce type de structure est
ce qu'on contrôle ou pas alors est ce
que c'est de la stigmatisation est ce
que c'est de l'islamophobie ou est-ce
que tout simplement le fait que je
pourrais dire dans les entreprises plein
d'exemples du même type à ce que vous
croyez encore à l'action le mexique
face à ces à ces sujets là si sensible
si compliqué aussi ma vie je sens bien
que c'est pas en une mesure
on arrive tous à se mettre d'accord sur
un aspect c'est qu'il suffit d'observer
ce qui se passe le phénomène de dire il
existe c'est vrai quand j'entends le
discours de monsieur je me dis qu'ils il
intellectualise bien les choses mais que
j'aimerais que j'aurais aimé qu'ils
disent effectivement il ya une
progression l'islamisme dans nos
quartiers c'est une évidence moi la
personne plus personne de nani c'est
vrai franchement et deuxième aspect et
là je balaie devant notre porte à nous
les médias c'est que je il serait temps
qu'on arrête de s'invectiver entre
présumé islamo-gauchiste présumé
islamophobe et qui on se contente juste
de 2,2 de montrer ce qui se passe et
quand il se passe quelque chose et je
rejoins ce que disait francis choix sur
les écoles et la déscolarisation c'est
pour moi le plus dangereux
on a été voir une école coranique en
seine saint denis et c'était absolument
monstrueux ce qui s'y passait et elle
n'a pas été fermé allez on s'arrête là
parce que j'aimerais qu'on aborde aussi
votre livre on va reparler de ces sujets
on attend ce plan du gouvernement avant
les élections on en vient donc à
apocalypse now
c'est le deuxième tome consacré au
suicide de la droite et à françois
fillon tout commence en 2014 avec un
déjeuner à l'elysée que vous révéler une
petite phrase en 2016 trouve prononcé à
sablé-sur-sarthe sarthe et après cela et
bien c'est le début d'une descente aux
enfers à une fois pour l'ancien premier
ministre qui ne s'en remettra pas
quand l'argent a le goût de la défaite
et même de la débâcle
on en parle avec vous dans un instant
juste après ce sujet d'ahmed stagiaires
qui qui imagine un seul instant le
général de gaulle mis en examen le
président de la république ne devrait
pas être un président de faits divers
prenant la parole à tord et à travers
lui jure prend la direction du
gouvernement
multipliant les petites promesses
démagogiques et occupant les rubriques
mondaine c'est la phrase qui déclenche
la vengeance des sarkozystes dans
apocalypse now l' enquête sur les années
fillon
les journalistes gérard davet et fabrice
lhomme offre un récit ultra détaillée de
la sphère des costumes
françois fillon est candidat à la
présidentielle de 2017 il veut être
calife à la place du calife
son but
éliminer nicolas sarkozy de la course
grâce à la ferme bygmalion elle concerne
les comptes de campagne de l'ancien
président robert bourgi avocat et
surtout sarkozyste pur jus et sur place
ils rentrer illico presto à paris et
promet de faire la peau à françois
fillon la sphère des costumes peut
surgir
elle va plomber le candidat fillon autre
révélation du livre l'argent perçu par
le couple fillon depuis 1981 dans ce que
les journalistes appellent une pme abus
très très lucratif
le canard enchaîné avait déjà révélé la
faire mais là c'est plus précis grâce à
des documents policiers que les
journalistes ont consulté un chiffre
fait l'effet d'une bombe
la petite pme auraient rapporté au total
1 million 300 6400 euros
majoritairement de l'argent public ce
chiffre c'est en grande partie tous les
salaires versés à pénélope sion pendant
des décennies par son employeur de mari
une affaire qui stoppe net la course en
tête pour la présidentielle 2017 de
françois fillon devant la justice
l'ancien premier ministre devra dans un
mois répondre de détournement de fonds
publics notamment à l'assemblée
nationale on veut tourner la page sur le
procès de françois fillon
non non je chipote franchement c'est
aujourd'hui le résultat des courses
c'est que la droite a perdu l'élection
présidentielle c'est que la droite est
dans un état difficile et que donc il
nous faut redresser la barre donc les
histoires des uns et des autres on a
tourné la page aujourd'hui on regarde
devant et on voit surtout construit une
nouvelle page pour la droite avant son
procès françois fillon va se défendre
sur france 2 il sera l'invité
exceptionnel de l'émission vous avez la
parole
la semaine prochaine mais au fait
pourquoi il ya eu une petite phase on va
dire de grandes réflexions sa part
d'ailleurs autour de lui et son
entourage n'étaient pas tous d'accord il
y en a qui lui disait il faut pas parler
d'autres au contraire qu'il me disait il
faut que tu parles je pense que c'est
vraiment son intime conviction à lui au
bout de quelques quelques mois de
réflexion qui lui s'est dit voilà moi je
veux raconter ma vérité j'ai 40 ans de
vie politique je ne veux pas finir ma
carrière sur une histoire de costard pas
finir sa carrière sur l'histoire de
costard et à ceux qui s'interrogent sur
un retour en politique de françois
fillon
son entourage est catégorique c'est non
c'est définitif
il ne le dit pas alors on va commencer
avec ce chiffre astronomique et
j'accueille au passage à la bouche et
pour que l'info soit un million trois
cent mille euros
même un peu plus c'est la somme
colossale donc qu'aurait rapporté ou
détourner la justice le dira la petite
pme familiale comme vous l'appelez de
pénélope et françois et françois fillon
en quarante ans de vie politique donc
c'est plus déjà que ce qu'on croyait
comment vous arrivez à consolider ce
chiffre si je puis dire c'est assez
simple en fait un ours qu'on a fait dans
ce dossier c'est qu'on a à la fois été
voir bon
nombre de témoins et on a également pu
consulter le dossier judiciaire
si judiciaire il ne ment pas parce que
dedans il ya des chiffres et des faits
précis et étayée par les enquêteurs qui
ont beaucoup travaillé et on arrive en
sur ce dossier on a consulté lordonnance
de renvoi entre autres qui renvoie
monsieur fillon devant le tribunal
correctionnel est dedans ils sont listés
les différentes pour imputation
budgétaire qui lui sont reprochés deux
ans il a quoi il ya l'argent public en
l'occurrence c'est à dire tout ce qu'il
a touché ici à l'assemblée nationale et
qui a été ensuite reversé également a
donc comme la même période fillon comme
assistante parlementaire
il y à aussi l'argent il était sénateur
qui là qu'il a donné à ces enfants qui
sont revenus ensuite sur son compte à
lui alors qu'il était assistant
parlementaire de leur père il y à aussi
l'argent la revue des dames en de leur
revue des deux mondes qui donc là de
l'argent privé
c'est un autre constat constat est donc
si vous additionnez un petit peu tout ça
vous allez vous arrivez à la somme d'un
million 300 6400 euros
alors on va partir voici sûr il ya
plusieurs clou dans le cercueil si je
peux dire le premier c'est 2014 c'est ce
déjeuner que vous aviez révélé dans le
pô le précédent livre déjeuner à
l'elysée entre jean pierre jouyet et
françois fillon et là on comprend très
bien que françois fillon fait tout pour
exiger demandé tout simplement au
pouvoir d'accélérer un peu les choses
s'il s'ils veulent avoir un espoir et au
passage voilà lui même s'assurer
s'assurer que on dégomme on dégomme
fillon
ça s'est vécue par à la sarkozy mais
même par la droite en général comme une
vraie très présent à oui c'est quelque
chose qui a été vécue de manière très
intense par une grande partie de la
droite et pas seulement les élus aussi
au niveau de jaillir des militants
d'abord parce qu'il ya une sorte de
fidélité à nicolas sarkozy et puis
surtout parce que il ya des choses qui
ne se font pas dans le milieu politique
on se fait on se fait des coups bas des
chausse-trappes etc mais j'allais dire
pas comme ça pas on allons voir l'ennemi
l'adversaire elle veut pas voir là
dedans sont déstabilisés qu'un de pierre
laval
je veux dire juillet il a été un peu à
gauche un peu à droite
le pont entre guillemets entre entre la
gauche et la droite mais mais surtout
nous ce qui nous a frappés
dans notre enquête c'est que comme vous
l'avez dit nous on avait révélé 7,7
cette affaire là l'ami enfin à la en
novembre 2014 précisément à l'époque ça
fait beaucoup de bruit et notamment pour
une raison c'est que jean pierre jouyet
avait eu l'imprudence de démentir ce qui
nous avait confirmé l'existence et le
contenu de ce déjeuner nous on avait pu
rapporter la preuve de deux ce qui nous
avait dit et donc il a été déstabilisé
les été poussé au bord de la démission
donc d'un seul coup c'est devenu la
sphère juillet mais c'est pas comme ça
que c était vécue à droite à droite ils
sont fichés un peu de savoir ce qu'avait
dit ou pas juillet à droite il se savait
que c'était vrai et donc à droite ils
sont nombreux et notamment chez les
sarkozystes se sont dit ce jour là
fillon le paiera un jour on sait pas
quand il le paiera et il a payé
d'ailleurs à roselyne bachelot
énormément énormément de deux
personnages à droite inquiets témoigne
dans votre livre qui dit très clairement
parce qu'elle est podcast on entendra
1go fond elle lui conseille de quitter
matignon on sent que ça devient très
compliqué l'enfer de matignon et lui dit
de toute façon après ça ils t'attendre à
nicolas sarkozy au bord de la route pour
te tirer dessus
ça se passe comme ça c'est exactement ça
et il fait très vite et en fait ils
étaient prévenus mais si vous les filles
ont il a commis 10 et alix bouilhaguet
tout dans le reportage il ya quarante
ans de vie politique derrière lui c'est
quelqu'un qui qui sait exactement
comment se passent les choses aussi il
sait exactement que durant ses 12 années
à matignon il restait cinq ans quand
même il s'est créé bourg l'inimitié
d'abord il ya les sarkozystes qui le
regardaient du coin de l'oeil parce
qu'il se disait celui ci il va essayer
de piquer la place de nicolas sarkozy un
jour ou l'autre
ensuite il lui reprochait de pas
travailler enfin il y avait des
copéistes qui lui en voulait pour ce qui
était de l'accession à la tête de l'ump
bref il s'est créé des ennemis partout
et ses rares amis ses rares amis vous
avez essayé de venir se faire venir son
plateau qui n'ont pas voulu
ses rares amis eux n'étaient pas traités
par françois fillon c'est à dire qu'en
fait c'est françois fillon c'est le
genre de type qui veut partir du jour au
lendemain 15 jours au ski et ne les
signe de vie à personne et ça ça pose un
souci en politique et le deuxième clou
dans le cercueil
on l'a entendu c'est cette petite phrase
pendant la primaire de droite
sablé-sur-sarthe 2016
qui imagine le général de gaulle mise en
examen et la robert bourgi il est là
l'avocat qu un des personnages les plus
truculents parce qu'il faut les inventer
on y croit même par existence
voilà il est plus grand que la vie
elle-même dit c'est terminé
cette fois ci je l'aurais exactement
c'est le sait la deuxième étape de la
mise à mort en quelque sorte il ya le
déclencheur juillet et comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure ils se sont dit on on le
laissera pas passer
et là ils ont l'occasion le discours de
sablé où effectivement filles on ose
comparer négativement sarkozy a à de
gaulle
il ya un homme qui joue un rôle
important robert bourgi certains avocats
qui a baigné dans l'univers on va dire
de la françafrique qui se trouve être
très bon ami très proche de nicolas
sarkozy mais qui aussi lié des liens
d'amitié avec françois fillon
donc il était pendant des années déchiré
entre les deux parce qu'il voyait bien
qu'il ne s'entendait plus et là il
bascule du côté de sarkozy ce
définitivement
et il se dit après ce que fillon a fait
à mon sarko parce qu'il sait pendant son
idole tribune air part je vais la jouer
il le dit dans des termes plus vulgaires
mais on peut les reprendre je vais le
voilà c'est comme ça qu'il a dit
là revendiquer skis plus à rien de
raconter les change pas ce que vont
reconstituer des dialogues exactement et
et ce qui est plus intéressant c'est
bien nicolas sarkozy il dit à nicolas
sarkozy je vais le décembre je vais le
plomber et nicolas sarkozy lui dit tu me
préviendra n'est ce pas qui me
préviendra et effectivement il vanne le
prévenir il va lui dire achète le
journal du dimanche
tel jour parce que c'est le jdd qui va
sortir cette information sur la base des
infos de robert bourgi
et le lendemain nicolas sarkozy nous
raconte robert bourgi appel bourgi et
lui dit merci donc le crime pour le coup
est vraiment signer alors on ne comprend
pas françois fillon si on ne comprend
pas son rapport à l'argent
d'ailleurs les costumes les milliers
d'euros de costumes offert par robert
bourgi n'y ont jamais posé aucun
problème on va écouter un extrait
d'ailleurs de vaud d'entretien puisque
vous avez décidé c'est assez inhabituel
de les faire entendre via des podcasts
avec la plateforme magellan roselyne
bachelot dont le cheminement fillon il
ya quand même eu une période où en 2010
la question s'est posée de son départ
pour lui la question s'est posée de son
départ comme premier ministre en a
discuté
ensemble je lui ai dit il faut que tu
partes la malédiction de matignon enfin
qui poursuit les candidats à la
présidence de la république il faut que
tu te fasses une virginité faut que tu
apparaissent comme un homme neuf pour
des raisons peut-être personnel familial
il s'est dit j'ai ce support dans la
capacité financière de prendre le risque
que ça fillon c'est un type qui a
toujours vécu de la politique il n'ya
pas de roue de secours j'ai un
background qui me permet le jour j qui
t'a politique d'avoir un boulot mais
c'est pas le cas de françois le fasse et
de 15 milliards aux banques c'est vrai
ça qu'on est très vite bruisser saharien
déjà avec une femme et cinq enfants
entretenir
mais voilà c'est on se pose quand même
des questions ça édifiant à cet extrême
parce que ça lève un grand tabou bien
bien sûr que l'argent est un élément
important dans la vie d'un élu quand on
est à l'époque premier ministre de
nicolas sarkozy
on a plus de 21000 euros mensuels c'est
pas rien quand même ça a été baissé
depuis par françois hollande bien quand
tu continues tu passes de matignon a
simple député entre guillemets simple
député on divise par quatre son salaire
et donc du coup avec cinq enfants à
gérer et un train de vie qui est
conséquent c'est pour ça qu'il reste
c'est une des principales raisons
nous on s'en doutait pas que tant que ça
c'est roselyne bachelot qui nous le
confie guy nous dit qu'ils nous la scène
c'était la principale raison pour
laquelle il restait alors ce qui obsède
tous vos interlocuteurs à droite c'est
de savoir qui l'a tué
qui est la taupe d'où vient la fuite qui
au fond a permis que des fiches de paie
de collaborateurs parlementaires en
l'occurrence de bananes fusion se
retrouve dans le canard enchaîné vous
allez évidemment pas me donner votre
souffle est ce que vous savez maintenant
déjà que vous savez on se doute on se
doute en fait de doute souvenu du coup
mais moi je ne passerai je ne parlerai
pas d'un coup je parlerai de plusieurs
coups déjà il faut vite d'avoir en tête
un truc l'information elle sort dans un
de madère le canard enchaîné et il sort
sur le travail de journalistes ils
travaillent ils font leur boulot
simplement les journalistes ils ne
sortent pas des informations comme ça
par hasard
ian harte ans à taux plein mais non ils
vont les chercher mais on leur donne ça
va ensemble et donc du coup il faut des
sources les sources est essentiel et ses
sources
eh bien elles sont essentielles pour
avoir des informations ici à l'assemblée
la suite vérifier
on a appelé ça qu'on apprend wells et
raconte année on a appelé un petit peu
tout le monde alors la grande muette à
l'assemblée c'est comme la grande muette
on a essayé de faire dans les sodas
général de la questure on a eu aucune
réponse à questure 1,7 sur cère les
financiers de ce la maison de ballet et
salah christophe palais je crois que ça
fait comme ça on n'a pas on n'a pas eu
de réponse interdiction alors donc on a
fait parler les questeurs les casseurs
de l'époque qui nous ont tous raconté
qu'effectivement ils ont tous essayé de
vérifier ce qui s'était passé
ils ont en apprendront qu'ils ont mené
une enquête interne mais ça vous révéler
l'existence d'une erreur enquête interne
après les révélations du canard enchaîné
oui parce que il faut bien comprendre
que nous on est on le but ce n'était pas
de dire tiens on va dévoiler les sources
du canard enchaîné on ne peut pas le
faire déontologiquement on n'a aucune
envie
en revanche ce dont on s'est aperçu à
force de discuter avec les leno des
protagonistes de l'histoire c'est que
cette traque à la fuite à la source
elle avait obsédé la droite donc on
s'est dit ça ça se raconte par contre ma
chère et découvrir qu'il ya eu des
enquêtes internes qui ont été menées
pour ce qu'on appelle la chasse à la
taupe notamment au sein de l'assemblée
nationale ont tous est assez
croustillant règne de la droite de la
gauche nous pour nous une quasi
certitude c'est quand même qu'il est
mort des coûts de ses propres amis à
droite bien évidemment bien évidemment
cc signé de tous les côtés simplement il
faut pas exclure qu'il y a il ya aussi
une enquête journalistique donc ça il
faut là il faut l'avoir en tête c'est
important alors l'autre dimension de ce
livre c'est l' enquête judiciaire autant
vous démontrer qu'il a beaucoup à se
reprocher françois fillon ça c'est
indéniable autant vous dites il a fait
l'objet d'un traitement de défaveur on
n'avait jamais vu autant de zèle dans la
magistrature tout est allé très vite
et pour la première fois la trêve
judiciaire qui est normalement respecter
pendant les campagnes présidentielles
explosent alors oui il faut préciser une
chose quand même quand on dit la dre
judiciaire qui est habituellement
respecté c'est exact mais c'est très
judiciaire elle n'a aucune substance ça
ne veut rien dire ce n'est pas juridique
était un coup de pub mythique c'est un
visage
une habitude qui est pas forcément pour
moi une bonne habitude pour la bonne et
simple raison qu'en france on est en
campagne électorale permanente
il ya une élection importante quasiment
tous les ans donc si on va jusqu'au bout
du processus de la trêve et judiciaires
éventuelles bas la très belle sera
permanente donc mais c'est vrai que
c'était une habitude et surtout pendant
la présidentielle
et là c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une
magistrature et j'ai l'ensemble de la
chaîne c'est-à-dire présidence du
tribunal parquet national financier
galerie financière des juges
d'instruction trois juges d'instruction
nommé dont un très offensif
tous ont eu en commun d'aller très vite
et est déjà l'idée presque dire de le
revendiquer
nous on donne la parole à quelqu'un qui
s'exprime très peu en général qui était
jusqu'à il ya encore quelques semaines
président du tribunal de grande instance
de paris
c'est lui qui a choisi de désigner un
juge qui est réputé très offensif le
juge tournaire
c'est le jeu on saura jamais on n'est
pas dans la tête des gens lui nous dit
qu évidemment il l'a fait il a fait son
choix en toute indépendance mais le plus
important surtout c'est qu'a été désigné
un juge qui était sans doute le seul
capable de mettre en examen françois
fillon aussi vite et juste avant la
présidentielle
et monsieur hayat nous le dit et je
trouve avec une sincérité qui est plutôt
à saluer il fait preuve de transparence
il dit attention il faut que maintenant
les politiques ça s'habitue à ce que ça
aille vite et sous-entendu demandé et il
y avait demandé à ce que la justice se
prononce en référé donc c'est lui aussi
qui a souhaité que la justice aille vite
dans cette affaire il ya eu un peu des
deux en fait pour expliquer que cette
trêve a été interrompu pendant une
présidentielle oui c'était une erreur
sans doute stratégiques de françois
fillon qui à un moment a dit mais
d'ailleurs moi je vais collaborer avec
la justice et ailleurs on révèle aussi
dans le livre que dans son camp beaucoup
l'ont critiqué a posteriori en dix ans
mais en fournissant tous les éléments la
justice il a permis aux policiers qui
enquêtaient à d'aller plus vite ce qui
est vrai est donc il va qu'on s'est tiré
une balle tirée d'un mental et surtout
il a provoqué la justice nous il ya une
injustice puis s'est mis lui même dans
la panade tout seul parce qu'en fait en
fournit son temps dans les man i les
enquêteurs ils ont toujours constitué
ils ont ainsi pu montrer que pénélope
fillon avait travaillé pour le député
fillon à partir de 1981 alors que dans
ses premières déclarations devant la
police françois fillon avec totalement
occulté cet aspect des choses
alors je dirais qu'on parle un peu de sa
communication puisque dans une semaine
il va avoir droit à une heure et demie
de tête à tête avec deux journalistes
sur le service public sur france 2
qu'est ce que vous en pensez qu est ce
qu ils cherchent à faire son procès dans
un mois tout juste
vous avez employé le terme de
communication c'est exactement ça c'est
à dire que en l'occurrence il veut
communiquer pour déminer cessant nana
oui c'est une c'est une pratique qui est
employé par sa communicante principal
s'agira de meo qui l'a fait avec carlos
ghosn qui va le faire avec françois
fillon
la vraie différence la vraie différence
c'est que là il sera face et ça c'est
plutôt gonflé sa part face à deux
journalistes de vrais journalistes qui
vont lui poser toutes les questions
ils vont ils vont ils vont faire le
travail et donc du coup c'est plutôt
gonflé de sa part est en fait je pense
que françois fillon je crois que c'est
lui qui a choisi un france 2 il va
s'expliquer mais il va aussi il va tout
mettre il va faire tout est sur la table
basse comme au poker fait tapis et il
peut s'en sortir parce qu'il est très
bon on débat et à la télévision
j'ajoute qu'une chose qui à mon avis est
importante pour avoir discuté en plus
avec pas mal de personnes qui sont dans
son entourage plus ou moins proche mais
qui nous parle encore malgré tout le
le but c'est d'éviter de se présenter
comme j'allais dire vous savez le
prévenu avec qui traîne son boulet et
qui arrive déjà à déjà un peu condamnés
or la dernière image que finalement les
français ont gardé de françois fillon
c'est le type humilier pendant la
présidentielle mis en examen et qui
disparaît du circuit s'il était revenue
au procès directement c'est la même
image qui serait resté donc quasiment
comme un coupable présumé dans le pour
l'opinion publique
lost une bataille d'image exactement là
en terme d'image qu'est ce qui va se
passer
il va parler des affaires il va se
défendre comme il pourra mais il va
reparler politique forcément et nos
confrères et consoeurs non dit
heureusement mais ils ont bien raison
ils vont faire leur boulot de
journaliste il va répondre mais du coup
à l'envi quand il sera au devant le
tribunal il se présentera en tant
qu'homme politique et éventuellement est
victime d'un complot parce qu'il usera
son ou de cette cantine va pas s'excuser
non c'est pas son genre d'un mot un jeu
je n'en sais rien l'apéritif vous si
vous n'avez pas c'est peut-être qu'ils
manquent d'un rien sur ce livre vous
avez tout le monde c'est pas le coc la
sarcosine deux entretiens et le
principal personnage du livre c'est pas
faute d'avoir essayé à de nombreuses
reprises depuis de nombreuses années
simplement
pour envoyer un dernier mail via son
avocat très circonstancié jeu quelques
jours avant la parution il ne veut pas
pourquoi parce que d'abord je crois
comprendre qu'il veut donner sa vérité
avec dans un avec un journaliste d'un
hebdomadaire très adroite dans un livre
à paraître une phase actuelle oui
d'apparaître je ne sais pas quand et par
ailleurs il nous ils nous détestent faut
dire ce qui est concrètement à ces
injustices et il a perdu plusieurs fois
contre nous donc très très vite
il ya d'autres procès parce que je
voudrais qu'on découpe brigitte qui
arrive le dossier d'igm à lyon le
dossier azibert avec les écoutes
téléphoniques
il va y avoir d'autres à nouveau un
grand déballage pour vous est-ce que la
droite peut s'en remettre pour vous elle
est d'ores et déjà carbonisée elle est
encalminée elle et elle est mourante
mais qu'on dit c'est un peu la fin de
notre livre c'est que en politique on
n'est jamais totalement mort allez on
arrête là merci brésil ce soir on nous
parlait de cédric villani va-t-il être
exclue finalement ou pas alors est ce
qu'il veut et exclu du parti en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que si on en croit
nos confrères d'rtl oui cédric villani
devrait être exclu et ce à compter du 27
février pourquoi c'est la date limite de
dépôt des candidatures donc si le dépose
sa candidature et ses listes pour être
candidat à la mairie par il devrait être
exclu
quand on écoute stanislas guérini en
zone parce que ça c'était du off
il dit oui il va devoir choisir mais la
main est toujours tendu la main de
benjamin griveaux et la porte est encore
ouverte
alors il ya d'autres scénarii qui
circule aussi ici à l'assemblée
nationale il ya par exemple une députée
la république en marche qui est assez
investis qui me disait qu'il pourrait y
avoir une suspension temporaire alors ça
va vous rappeler meriem la vieille
politique quand par exemple pierre
charon s'était porté candidat aux
sénatoriales pour la pour la droite pour
l'ump à paris et il était dissident face
à chantal jouanno il avait donc été
suspendues par l'entente réintégré après
les élections c'est ce qui pourrait
éventuellement se passer et puis une
troisième possibilité cette d'être exclu
alors ça c'est un poids lourd de la
république en marche et si à l'assemblée
nationale qui le dit d'être exclu après
le premier tour
pourquoi parce que finalement il dit
ce serait une gigantesque conneries
qu'il soit exclu maintenant l'élection
va se jouer entre les deux tours il faut
absolument que cédric villani s'il
arrive derrière benjamin griveaux puis
se rallier à lui entre les deux
commencent à réaliser dans la majorité
il se met en marche les députés ils sont
plutôt catastrophé atterré désabusé il
pense que la machine à perdre est
enclenché et ce surtout depuis le
journal du dimanche et ce fameux sondage
ifop qui donne rachida dati devant
benjamin griveaux anne hidalgo en tête
et surtout benjamin griveaux deux points
seulement devant cédric villani on
al'impression donc que cette machine à
perdre être enclenchée il ya des
tensions il ya des crispations au groupe
mais pour l'instant ça reste assez
circonscrit aux députés qui soutiennent
les deux camps celui de benjamin
griveaux de cédric villani
il ya aussi des députés qui se disent oh
là là il ya la fronde sous françois
hollande on s'en souvient c'était
mortifère on veut surtout pas que que
ces instruments aux devises
il ya ces fameux légitimiste qui disent
aussi on ne comprend pas le jusqu'au
boutisme de cédric villani qui va
finalement nous faire perdre paris en
tout cas on veut éviter à tout prix que
les problèmes du parti soit ne peut y
avoir des effets sur les marcheurs ici à
l'assemblée si cédric villani samba est
exclu écoutez en fait il ya les
responsables de la majorité qui
craignent surtout finalement que le
cédric villani puisse créer un groupe
dissident
c'est à dire que la scission il ya il a
déjà créé un groupe qui s'appelle
accélérons avec matthieu orphelin pour
promouvoir l'écologie il
ils craignent évidemment ça pour
l'instant c'est pas dans les intentions
ni dans la volonté du camp villani mais
évidemment ça pourrait arriver d'autant
qu' il ya eu pas mal de bisbille avec
des députés de la majorité à cause les
municipales qui sont exclus qui sont
partis en fait du parti et qui sont
maintenant apparenté au groupe et donc
tout cela pourrait éventuellement se
rassembler bon on n'est pas au bord de
la scission tout de même on n'est pas au
bord de la scission parce que même pas
mort dans le dans le camp finalement de
cédric villani on n'est quand même pas
prêt à mourir pour lui
wen a même un qui me disait qu'il
pourrait se mettre en retrait parce que
aujourd'hui ne cautionne pas finalement
cette division ces dissensions donc
voilà le nouveau monde et ressemble la
peur certains mots la politique ça reste
un métier pourriez faire un autre
bouquin la haine à l heure où m we be
seen as les bonis de lezennes et fillon
c'est chez fayard et c'est signé gérard
davet et fabrice lhomme passe-passe lit
comme un thriller merci à bien j'ai
voulu ni sur le plateau de lcp
c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]